one of the questions when it comes to a
story like this which can perhaps seem
like the media talking about itself is
how much the public really cares in this
case though they do and that also comes
with some risks before that we've been
taking a look at how public interest in
the story the identity of the BBC
presenter in question has played out on
social media that was one hashtag on
Twitter and here is another the most
prominent hashtags around the issue at
that Peak yesterday they'll use some 25
000 times that was around the same time
that the young person at the center of
the story said via lawyers that nothing
inappropriate or unlawful happened with
the unnamed presenter Twitter isn't of
course the entire world but even on Tick
Tock the story is getting lots of
attention here's a similar sort of
hashtag and the second hashtag again
similar to what we saw on Twitter again
very popular up there and across the web
too people are searching for this this
is the interest on Google with people
seeking out information searching is
different from posting though especially
when it come comes to specific names it
could have serious consequences and even
lead to libal action a number of names
have been circulating to the extent that
some BBC presenters have made clear
their innocent and unconnected to the
case among them Jeremy Vine Gary lineker
Rylan Clark and Nikki Campbell we've
charted how many times their names were
posted on Twitter along with two other
BBC presenters who've not made any
public comment and tonight Jeremy Vine
has called on the unnamed presenter to
reveal themselves to take away some of
the virtual these presenters are getting
online reliable law applies to everyone
not just journalists now that means
anyone posting names like this could
face serious consequences I think the
law of privacy is in a really difficult
place in particular there's a real gray
area about when journalists can report
the names of people subject to these
allegations I think it is a huge uh
phenomenon on social media over the last
few days people just don't know what the
potential consequences are they might
think it's a laugh but of course they
are really damaging allegations to the
people who are not involved it makes for
a very modern media frenzy traditional
Publishers avoiding names because of
privacy laws and so fueling rampant and
potentially damaging speculation online